النجمه روجينا بتطل على الجمهور في رمضان
السنه بشكل مختلف من خلال مسلسل ستهم اللي
بتقوم ببطولته وبالطل فيه بثوب رجالي
وشخصيه وامراه صعيديه باحثه وكاشفه لقضايا
تمس المراه المصريه والعربيه العمل من
تاليف ناصر عبد الرحمن واخراج رؤوف عبد
العزيز روجينا في بتلعب دور ستهم الست
الصعيديه اللي بعد وفاه زوجها بتدخل في
صراعات وبتضطر للتنكر في هيئه رجل لتواجه
صعوبات الحياه اللي بتقابلها والمسلسل
مستوحى من قصص حقيقيه
معرفش كيف الناس بتدافع عنك
حتى وانت كيف الميتين
[موسيقى]
خلاص
خلاص ما بقتش خلقات
النسوان
[موسيقى]
ومعنا من القاهره النجمه روجينا اهلا فيك
معانا كل عام وانت بالف خير
كيفك كيفك يا ست ام اي والله انت طالعه
بدور الشخصيه يعني بلبسوا الشخصيه صراحه
انت طالعه طبعا خلينا نوضح للمشاهدين من
اللوكيشن ولسه بتصوري
ايوه بالضبط طيب عشان نشرح للمشاهدين
اللبس هذا الان انت بتصوري فيه انت طول
الوقت قررتي في هذا المسلسل خلينا نبتدي
من الناحيه الشكليه قبل ما ندخل في الامور
الاخرى تتخلي تماما عن فكره انه الست
الحلوه اللي بتحط ميك اب اللي بتلبس حلو
اللي عامله شعرها والكلام ده كله قديش صعب
صراحه على ست انه تتخلى عن هذا كله وتظهر
بهذا اللبس يعني
لا هو صعب جدا انه ممثله
ترمي كل ده وتتخلى عن شكلها وعن انوثتها
وعن المكياج واعتقد ان كل الستات المكياج
مهم جدا جدا بالنسبه لهم بس هو انا
بالنسبه لي كان تحدي كبير قوي كان ممثله
انه انا هقدر اعمل دور زي ده ولا لا هوافق
على تحدياته ولا لا هتخلى عن حاجات كثيره
قوي بالنسبه لي انا ببقى حباها او مش انا
بس اي انثى يعني يعني فانا انا انا
بالنسبه لي كانت حاله جديده وانا دايما اي
شخصيه جديده
مختلفه
دايما بحب اروح لها ويبقى حاصل كده حاله
تحدي بيني وبين الشخصيه دي
واهم حاجه انا بقول انه الاخلاص يعني
البني ادم دايما لما بيخلص لاي شيء هو
بيعمله حقيقي بيوصل للناس لا هو فعلا يعني
المسلسل من وقت ما بدا وهو يعني الناس
متابعه لاحداث اللي فيه لانه كمان يمكن كل
حلقه فيها احداث جديده يعني ما في حلقه
بتعدي من غير احداث صراحه وواحده من
الاشياء اللي على طول صارت قصه حلاقه شعرك
اول شيء هي صوره سربت قبل المسلسل هل صحيح
انه تسربت من داخل العمل وصارت مشكله
اه طبعا طبعا لان احنا كنا احنا يعني
بدانا تصوير وفي حلاقه الشعر ده بدري قوي
وكنا شايفين انه ده بلوف في المسلسل يعني
لما ينزل ساعه العرض كان يعني حاجه كانت
مهمه جدا جدا للمسلسل وقبل التصوير وقبل
رمضان باربع خمس ايام كده الصوره اتصورت
الحقيقه يا استاذ رؤوف عبد العزيز نزعج
جدا جدا واستيق من اللي حصل وللاسف الصوره
اتسربت من اللوكيشن لان صوره انا واستاذ
رؤوف اللي فيها ايوه
الناس كلهم بتسال انه
هل فعلا روجينا حلقت شعرها تماما ولا انتم
يعني هذه خدعه بالمكياج والاشياء هذه كلها
بصي انا مش عايزه افتكر المرحله دي من
حياتي وعايزه انساها تماما تماما لانها
مرحله
استاذ رؤوف خد فتره كبيره قوي قوي عشان
يقنعني بكده بس انا انا دايما بقول انه
انا تحت امر الشخصيه اللي بعملها يعني انا
وافقت ان انا البس طوب الرجال وافقت ان
انا احط العمه طول المسلسل وافقت دي كلها
تفاصيل للشخصيه فالحقيقه هو بيعمق بيعمق
فكر ستهم بيعمق فكره الست اللي رفضت انها
تكون ست
ووافقت انها تلبس توب الرجال عشان تقدر
تاخد حقها او انها اتظلمت او انها عايزه
تنزل مجتمع عشان تشتغل وتعيش
فالحقيقه انا كنت ماشيه وراه الشخصيه مش
ماشيه وراء اي حاجه تانيه ولانه عمل
بالنسبه لي مختلف وجديد في اي حاجه كنت
بقول عليها لا اه يعني يعني حاجات الصعبه
جدا جدا لازم يتقال عليها لا كنت بقول
عليها اه مش ده بس في المسلسل لا انا كان
عندي
الصعوبات جدا جدا في اللوكيشنات التصوير
في الاماكن في الشغل واكتشفت انه انه
العمل الرجالي حقيقي صعب ومرهق جدا جدا
بالنسبه للستات يعني الست اللي بتنزل
تمتهن مهنه الراجل دي ست مليار راجل لا هو
احنا بشكل عام احنا بمليون راجل دايما
احنا دايما احسن من الرجال بس كده يعني بس
كده هتزعلينا منك وتحسسينا ان شغل الرجال
يعني نحن ما نقدر عليه لا احنا نقدر عليه
المفروض يعني لا لا اقوى من الرجال فعلا
في طبعا احنا اقوى من الرجال وطبعا انه
ربنا خصص ست بقوه بدنيه وفكريه والست
بتقدر تعمل حاجات الراجل ما بيعملهاش يعني
الست بتحمل وتربيه وتكبر وتشتغل في نفس
الوقت انما كان في فعلا فعلا
واذكى ههه انت عايزه تضيعيني مع الرجاله
ههه انما لا في مهن حقيقي حقيقي جسمانيا
صعبه بالنسبه للست حقيقي طيب فيعني انت
حلقتي شعرك وتقبلت المشهد
طبعا طبعا لا هو مش مشهد واحد بتعيش فتره
في حيات المسلسل قصدي تقبل مشهدك انت
انت كانثى طبعا
لا ما تقبلتش وما كنتش ببص لنفسي في
المرايه وكانوا بيعملوا لي مكياج وانا مش
قاعده قدام المرايه خالص
انا انا كمان وانا بمثل انا انا ما بشوفش
انا ما بتفرجش على شغلي يعني انا في ناس
كتير تعملي المشهد وتروحي تتفرجي انت
كويسه ولا مش كويسه انا انا عمري ما
اتفرجت على شغل فانا بعمل مكياج ما كنتش
ببص على نفسي ما كنتش بقعد قدام مرايه
احنا ما بنعملش مكياج انا بترش كده حاجه
بمنتهى القلم لاني بترش بمده زي العربيات
عارفه العربيات بطاش حاجه كده بسبرتو يعني
انا بحط سبيرتو على وشي عشان ما يبقاش لون
يبقى كانها الشمس خبطتها فالشمس لما لما
بالضبط كده في البني ادم لما بيبقى في
الشمس ما بيبقاش لونه واحد حته غامقه حته
فاتحه لانه طبيعي طيب هو الحقيقه يعني يا
روجينا انت اتبهدلتي بدال العمل يعني سواء
يعني
اللوكيشنات الشكل واللي بيتابعوا العمل
شايفين صراحه
الدور قديش بتقدميه من قلبك يعني ما بدي
احرق العمل بس انه فيه مشاهد رائعه صراحه
لك طيب خلينا نشوف يمكن بعض الاشياء اللي
كمان الناس تتكلموا عنها مثلا قصه انه
قالوا انه تلبس روجينا عامله هوليود سمايل
مو لايق مع الشكل العام اللي عملته كيف
بتردي على هذا الكلام
انا عندي انا عندي في في المسلسل الحلقه
الاولى فقط هي انثى ولازم تبقى انثى جميله
جدا
وبترقص وزي ما شفنا كلنا في او بتحب لانه
ده المتنفس الوحيد اللي في المسلسل كله ان
احنا نشوفها انثى ولازم كنا نشوفها انثى
حلوه جدا وحطة مكياج احمر وحاجات كده
فده ما كانش يتعارض انما بعد كده انت
شايفه اسناني اه انا لو احب
غامقه ناخد روجينا صوره كامله
اعطينا ابتسامه ساحره خلابه
بلاش بلاش ههه
بلاش لان هي لما بتنزل لما بتنزل حقيقي من
من المجهود ما بيبقاش فيه حاله الاهتمام
بنفسها ولانه هي بتعيش في الشارع فتره
طويله فبنلاقي اسنانها اختلفت بتخش في
خناقه ومعركه بتنضرب في سنتها بتطير
فهي عندها مراحل كثيره قوي انما يعني انا
انا بشكر استاذ الحقيقه ناصر عبد الرحمن
لانه عامل عمل كاتب عمل جيد جدا جدا وانا
بقول انها ملحمه وانه تكريم للمراه
المصريه ولا عربيه بشكل عام
وهي يعني
ده الموضوع انت كتبتي بوست عن ده الموضوع
قلتي انه يعني هو تكريم للمراه في صوره
عمل درامي ده حقيقي ده حقيقي ده حقيقي لا
حقيقي وبشكر كمان استاذ رؤوف عبد العزيز
لانه هو اللي اختارني للشخصيه انا ما
اختارتش هذا العمل استاذ رؤوف هو اللي
اختار الشخصيه واختارني فيها وده كان
بالنسبه لي تحدي اصعب لاني ما اخترتش
شخصيه هو مخرج شافني في شخصيه فكان
بالنسبه لي انا عايزه اثبت له دايما انه
انا قد الشخصيه اللي بعملها
فعشان كده لما كان بيحصل
بهدله في التصوير او بترمي في الرمل او
بقع او انا كنت موافقه لانه كنت عايزه
الحقيقه اقدم الشخصيه كما ينبغي
روجينا بس اخر سؤال سريعه البطوله تاخرت
انها توصل للروجينا ولا وصلت لروجينا في
الوقت الصح
ما فيش حاجه اتاخرت كله بمعاد واللي كاتبه
ربنا في معاده بيبقى احسن
واهم في التوقيت اللي بعده ربنا انا بشكر
ربنا جدا جدا على انه بعد فدوى دور فدوى
واللي انا بعتقد ان الدور ده عمل لي عند
ناس كتير حاله محبه وترند وثقه وعمري
وحاله كده يا عمري بالضبط كده
فدور خلاني اتاح لي ان انا هي مش البطوله
اتاحلي ان انا اختار ادوار انا شايفه انها
تقدمني كممثله بشكل اقوى مدخرتش ولا حاجه
انا كان بعدها انحراف والان سبتهم لا كان
بعدها بنت السلطان ثم انحراف ثم سبتهم
روجينا انت الان يعني بهذا العمل احس
بتردي على كل احد انك انت يعني واحده من
اعظم الممثلات صراحه يعني دورك
رهيب رهيب رهيب مشاهدك في اللي بتوثق
الخساره والاشياء دي كلها
يعني تبكي انا يعني بقول للناس اتفرجوا
انتوا انتوا احكوا الصراحه يعني قد اكون
انا منحازه لك خلي الناس يشوفوا بنفسهم
الرجينا نورتينا اليوم وما نبغى ناخذ من
وقتك اكثر من كده لانه عارفه انه وراكي
تصوير حبيبتي فالله يعينك الله يعينك
وشكرا لك كانت معنا من القاهره النجمه
روجينا
[موسيقى]